our adverts for junk food which are
targeted at children could be banned to
try to tackle the problem of obesity the
committee of advertising practice has
launched a public consultation on
proposals to limit where they can be
shown in newspapers magazines and online
the bar would bring the regulations in
line with television ads so should
adverts for unhealthy food aimed at
children be made illegal or should we
trust parents to take decisions for
their families had to talk about this
now adopt Ellie Lee director of the
Centre for parenting culture studies at
the University of Kent and Lee at Hughes
Joshi parenting journalist and author of
raising children to primary years very
good morning to you both and dr. le Lee
let's start with you should we ban
adverts which highlight sugary food for
kids no I don't know I think this is
symptomatic of the ban happy times we
live in I mean this proposal is being
made in full admission and recognition
that there's no reason to think that
children eat what they do or have the
bodies the size that they do because of
advertising that's well-known and what's
being said really is well we might as
well do this because we can because
people involved in a lobby of a tsipras
Lobby which is really hostile to the
food industry wants them bound and
there's no reason for it and I think
that my concern about this I mean I've
got no interest in the food industry
particularly what I'm concerned about is
that this Lobby that's no so hostile
towards food manufacturers and what they
call bad foods and junk foods is
actually also has some very negative
attitudes towards parents in the way it
looks at things and some very negative
attitudes towards families I think
parents and families vast ways of whom
perfectly happily give their children
food produced by manufacturers from
formula milk through convenience foods
through McDonald's through Coco Pops and
a routinely patronized as uneducated
victims of the food industry or actually
a now viewed with pretty much open
hostility and disgust the way parents
who take their kids to McDonald's are
talked about is really characterised
frequently by disgust and I think that
they need to back off and leave it up to
parents to
raise their kids in the way that they
want to including feeding them I also
think that these people need to have a
good look in a mirror in relation to the
situation that we now have with kids who
increasingly preoccupied with what
they're eating increasingly worried
about what their bodies look like
everybody wants to blame skinny models
in celebrities but I think that this
Lobby is actually culpable and they
should have a good think about what
they're doing to screw up children
through their relentless pathologize
ation of perfectly okay foods there's
nothing wrong with these foods well Leah
Joshy who's a fairly vocal attack there
on this idea what do you think is it
really going to make any difference
banning ads on sugary treats look at the
end of the day we you know we can look
out there for evidence of whether these
adverts actually influence children's
eating habits and families purchasing
habits and it is hard to find a very
firm link between the two but I don't
from minute believe that the food
industry would be spending millions
advertising to targeting children if it
didn't work if it didn't influence what
we buy as families so you know I I think
this is a good measure I think that we
have a huge significant obesity problem
at all age groups in this country 1/3 of
children who leave school are either
overweight or obese and the obesity
issue is costing the NHS 5.1 billion
pounds a year to deal with so we have to
do something else to go on donnelly
sorry I just lost you there okay I'm in
it but I think I think what's been
demonstrated here exactly what I'm
saying there is just a ban happy
attitude which basically says even
though we've got no reason for saying
this at all we just don't like these
adverts very much we don't like parents
who give their kids these foods we don't
like what kids bodies look like so we're
going to ban things and doctor lately
really out of order but the point that
they use Joshua's making is about the
obesity crisis and it is a crisis that
we have in this country with 1/3 of
children it's a moral panic I don't
think that there
you know crisis anybody who writes
sensibly about this should say we should
use the word crisis lightly because when
people start talking about a crisis okay
but it's a problem at times been
exaggerating a situation and I am quite
genuinely much much more concerned about
the fact that lots of very little kids
now and really bothered about being too
fat you know you're making them really
worried or concerned about what their
bodies look like I think that's a really
unhealthy thing to do to kids Lea huge
Joshy is at a point that we are becoming
obsessed with our children's weight my
five-year-old son got a letter home
saying that he was overweight because of
his BMI he's not overweight and actually
we're bringing up a generation possibly
as you heard therefore dr. Lee of
parents and families who are so obsessed
with their children's way they become so
focused on it and restrictive that it's
actually detrimental to them in the long
term it's about balance and yes you can
go too far the other way but at the same
time we've got plenty of families who
actually are not doing anything to stop
their children eating deeply unhealthy
foods so you know we have to take action
because parents aren't they're not
saying no you can't eat those crisps or
chocolate you can't you we can't rely on
some parents to do this what do you
think mental premise is completely wrong
and I really object to the unscientific
and nonsensical language that's now a
talked used to talk about food good food
bad food junk food I mean what a silly
term is that food is not junk food is
not bad that includes crisps biscuits
McDonald's breakfast cereals they are
neither junk nor fat they're just food
and misson is really not a very
scientific person okay let me come here
because Leah Leah Hughes Joshi all of
the junk food if that's what you called
it was all around when we were kids you
know I would have eaten Coco Pops and
biscuits all day long if I could have
done you know and and it wouldn't and it
wasn't necessarily down to my parents
although they were strict to say no
actually you have to learn when you
become you know an adult eventually cell
control yeah we do and parents ideally
need to be teaching children to to or
encouraging children to have more
self-control but actually that's not
always happening there are a third of
children who are obese or overweight
it's a fact that is not me making it up
and we need to be doing something to
help those parents and to help those
families ensure that their children
don't grow up to add to those obesity
statistics and to say these sorts of
food are not foods and not bad is just
quite frankly ridiculous of course if
you only have your bands a month it look
if those foods contribute to a child
ending up overweight or obese then
clearly that is bad for their health the
food in itself if you only have it once
a month sure I accept that it's not the
end of the world it is something that
clearly contributes but frankly you're
being quite patronizing clearly there is
a link between unhealthy food and
children being overweight and that being
unhealthy for those children and yeah
it's irrefutable it's not irrefutable
there's nothing that's irrefutable
answer certainly dr. Lee it is a fact
it's irrefutable so the definitions that
are used to measure obesity and
overweight are completely refutable and
they are a subject of significant debate
for example body mass index and the
measure of it as you know if you read
stuff is subject to debate and the
construction of these statistics is a
matter of contest and debate number one
number two the way in which we
understand nutrition and the science of
nutrition is a science and the concept
that you are using have departed very
very considerably to any sensible
mobilisation of scientific concepts once
people start talking about food in
moralized categories which of the
categories you're using go down bad or
not scientific categories their moral
categories something is good something
is bad it's not a language that comes
from science dr. Lee you're doing you
are involved in the moral
zatia of forms of behavior and it's got
nothing to do with nutrition it's got
nothing to do with food nothing to do
with the proper understanding of
problems and this is really a discussion
that has got completely out of control
dr. Lee as a result its having very
negative consequences for families and
she totally isn't that the language that
we use when we talk to our children we
say you can't have that back that it's
unhealthy it's not good for you
the two are kind of equated is the
language that we use isn't it and I
think it's a problematic language I
think it's a moralized language which
doesn't help children understand
anything about nutrition it doesn't help
them understand anything about the
science of food it doesn't help them
understand anything about components
going to do it okay sure but when you're
talking to a3 I don't language it's food
it's some chips in a burger but do you
know if they're interested in an
appropriate point in their development
in having a discussion about the science
of nutrition then you can talk to them
about the science of nutrition which
means talking about calorie if you're
trying to hydrate bitumen if you're
trying to instill values in a young
child how do you talk to them if it
doesn't okay so okay so now this is
interesting because values are about
morality values are a moral concept and
it's to do with a moral framework about
the way we want to live our lives in the
way that we want to go on with each
other and there is a huge weight of
sociology which is very interesting
their food and food habits as part of
normal moral norms within communities
and what all of that sociology
recognizes is that pleasure enjoyment
joy and community are probably the
single most important things that go
along with food in a moral sense and I
think that what's going on there with
the way that we've come to talk about
food in a very kind of pathologized
negative language which takes all of the
joy and the pleasure out of it and only
ever talks about food as a problem it's
very very negative because I mean that's
a mere Hughes Joshi as a parenting
author do you accept that that actually
we're putting moral judgments on our
food and we need to talk use different
language to educate our children I think
the idea is standing there in the
supermarket when your four year old is
asking to buy a multipack of extremely
unhealthy they are unhealthy chocolate
bars you know and having a great
scientific and moral debate for them
it's just unrealistic we need to talk to
her you know at the end of the day these
foods are unhealthy there is no thing
that what does that mean what do you
mean unhealthy if you eat too many
options it's unhealthy because if you
eat too much of it you gain weight and
then you can have health problems it's
so cool it's common sense
you know they do that radiation between
overweight and health is very
complicated okay it's a complicated
debate and we'll have to leave it there
very interesting story both though
doctor le ly Lea Hughes Joshi do let us
know audience what you think tweet me at
Samantha what do you think are very
fiery debate there what do you think
about whether the food you give your
children the names you call it unhealthy
or otherwise is that correct terminology
is it educating them or confusing them
let us know what you think